and then five big beasts as they're
called of the Labour Party have given
their backing to the Prime Minister's
negotiations with Europe the group who
were all against joining the European
community or staying in it
in 1975 have signed an open letter
arguing the case for remaining in the EU
I'm joined now by one of them the former
Home Secretary David now of course Lord
blanket he's in Derby a very good
morning to you lord Blunkett simple
question to start why have you felt the
need to write this letter I think to get
across the very simple message that
people who were sceptical 40 years ago
may still be skeptical of the way in
which Europe works as a bureaucracy and
I'm certainly a euro skeptic but
recognize the catastrophe that would
happen if we pulled out of Europe now 40
years on globalization is increased
apace the whole world is much more
insecure despite the collapse of the the
Iron Curtain and the conflict that that
brought we now have as we all know a
threat of entirely new forms of
terrorism organized criminality the
massive people movements that have
occurred because of conflicts elsewhere
and we need to be part of the European
Union to deal with those enormous issues
well this one name that springs to mind
that fits the bill on what you've
described the 40 year journey and he is
of course the current leader of the
Labour Party Jeremy Corbyn wisely signed
it well because we were dealing with
those who've been dealing been
responsible for and held positions as
Home Secretary who had been actually
involved with as well more foreign
secretaries the way in which you have to
do business with other countries in
other words the ability to be able to
appreciate and this is quite difficult
because you don't have patronized the
the people we're talking to and those
who we want to persuade to vote we're
not actually saying to them at least I
hope we're not that you know we know
best because we've been through this and
we know that if we
of negotiating on our borders dealing
with the cross-border issues the
European wide challenges we're not
saying listen to us because we're wise
we're saying listen to us because we
were skeptical
we've been won over but we've been a run
over by a lifetime of experience seeing
what suddenly just take take the border
is young for a moment if Britain is not
part of and cooperating with Europe as a
whole in terms of firstly protecting the
wider European border and then secondly
being able to be part of a European
Union where we've put our border
controls on French soil we will have no
say whatsoever and we'll have no means
of preventing people flooding across
Europe and into the British Isles and I
think people are really not fully
understood just what the catastrophe
would happen right if those borders were
simply open to the UK but you just don't
Jeremy Corbyn you rather dodge that I
mean of course if he did become Prime
Minister he would have to deal of course
with with many many foreign nations but
you're saying the qualification is you
either had to be a shadow home or
foreign secretary you got Neil Kinnock
there
did you actually ask Jeremy Corbyn to
sign the letter not as far as I'm aware
because Jeremy had not been in a
position of authority over those years
and that's what many people liked about
him to be honest that he wasn't that he
was what Russia that way what about
Hillary
well what about Hillary Ben I mean he's
now there is now the Foreign Affairs
shots you should be shot
yeah but he wasn't he way although he
was a minister including in my team he
was not a he was not at home Secretary
was he all right well the chart of the
charges do you think Jeremy Corbyn do
you think Jeremy Corbyn has been as
enthusiastic as he could be about
remaining in the European Union
I don't think Jeremy's bought ever been
terribly enthusiastic about the European
Union but that's not to say he's a
again staying in is it and there's lots
of people watching this program this
morning and millions of people we're
going to have to win over who are not
enthusiastic who have been skeptical and
in the next whatever months it is three
months I'm going to have to be worn over
if we don't have an economic a social
and an international crisis because our
withdrawal from Europe would bring those
things inevitably
just to come back to the point I was
making earlier most countries are
concerned with people who come into the
country and not those who leave so when
I negotiated with Nicolas Sarkozy the
venn interior minister in France all
those years ago back in 2002 that we
would have immigration and security
officers on French soil that was an
enormous step forward both of the UK and
I mean enormous commitment by France and
they did it because we were partners we
were literally in this together they've
got a problem
we were potentially having a massive
problem of over a hundred thousand
refugees coming in at that time those
measures reduced those coming in as
refugees to less than 30,000 if we open
those borders again and that's what it
would mean because we pull our
immigration and security back to Kent
you can imagine just for a moment that
the prep the French would have no
imperative whatsoever to stop people
leaving their country just a question on
that Lord brung it while we're
revisiting the past do you now think it
was an error to not bring in
transitional controls when Poland and
others joined the European Union when
you of course were in power no I don't
because they'd have run out in 2011
anyway that many of those who came have
made a tremendous contribution and have
paid taxes and national insurance bear
in mind this when when the the the new
arrangements came in in 2004 we
discovered that 40% for old percent of
those who actually registered and
therefore were paying tax on - insurance
and were counted as new immigrants were
actually already in
country many of them working
clandestinely you have people working
openly with visas and with permission or
you have them in the sub economy under
undercutting rates of pay under cutting
conditions and all the things that go
either and what about another idea from
those times I remember you were a strong
advocates of identity cards ID cards it
shows who's entitled to be in the
country who's entitled to use the NHS
who's entitled to access benefits do you
think that should be revisited yes I do
as a matter of fact I would do it a
different way now because people
panicked over the idea of an ID card
rather than the fact that you were going
to have a clean register of knowing who
was here who is entitled to public
services to to work here in the light I
would simply say that we would have all
all adults would have a passport 82% do
already that that passport would
obviously be linked to biometric
identifiers and that would be linked to
a claim register and that would have got
round the problem and we learn as we go
along it said as Tony Blair once wisely
said we've just learned how to do things
when nobody wants us to do them any
longer and just a last thought about
Jeremy Corbyn and whether he gets
involved in the campaign or not do you
think you might not even be leader by
the time of a referendum and I'm
thinking about the May elections in all
their various forms if this is not a
very good job labour do you think you
should consider his future no I'm not a
company so I didn't vote for Jeremy I
wish him well there's absolutely no way
in which there's going to be a change of
leader between now and the referendum
and anybody who thinks there is is
living in cloud cuckoo-land and do you
think there are those in your party who
will look at this and say this big
beasts letter and say well what are they
doing they're joining a camera and lead
campaign oh I think there's a very real
danger as there was with the Scottish
referendum of people actually using the
fact that this common cause across
people of all different political
persuasions mainly on they stay in but
also on the
to campaign and saying we'll judge you
by who you're associating with rather
than by what you're saying and what the
outcome will be I think that's a very
real danger and we've got to face it and
we've got to face people up to the fact
that they're making a momentous decision
about the future of the country and not
about David Cameron and the government
despite the fact that David Cameron
forged this referendum and has done what
he's done in order to be able to solve
problems inside his own party we're
bigger than that the issue of Britain's
place in Europe and the world is bigger
than any of this and that's why we've
got to get out there in campaign
fantastic give you to spare the time to
talk to us Lord Blanc it's very good see
thank you very much indeed thank you
very much